three two one ignition and lifts off of
Charlie
[Music]
now as a reminder we are flying Starling
satellites today and there we saw it
live separation confirmed separation
confirmed we can now see the starlink
satellites Starling is a constellation
of fairly small communication satellites
that exist in low earth orbit and the
idea behind Starling Elon musk's idea
was to replace the dependence of the
internet on cables about 95 percent of
internet traffic is handled on undersea
cables to replace that with networks of
low earth orbit satellites which means
that you'll be able to get the internet
access the internet anywhere around the
world about three thousand
Starling satellites have been put into
orbit another 12 000 are due to go into
orbit and eventually Elon musk's idea is
that there might be forty thousand more
than forty thousand forty two thousand
uh low earth orbit styling satellites
very small satellites which would access
the internet anywhere on the globe
that's the long-term vision
[Music]
in the Ukraine war the importance of
starlink is that Elon Musk gave the
ukrainians access to his 3 000 odd
satellites and the orbit of many of
those have been launched has been
changed to help the Ukrainian so they
are more available over Ukrainian
territory and what it has done is given
the ukrainians a secure and extremely
reliable Battlefield management
communication system which is better
than anything that the Russians have and
the point about it is that it's secure
and so this this constellation of 3000
satellites soon to be maybe twelve
thousand gives the ukrainians a an easy
way of communicating from one part of
the battlefield to any other part of the
battlefield more or less instantly the
Russians have tried to penetrate it and
every time they make a breakthrough
SpaceX is able to change the coordinates
change the the architecture of its
system so the Russians have never been
able to actually break into it and the
point about it is that the ukrainians
are winning this war on the ground
because they're more agile than the
Russians that have been able to as it
were control the battle and make the
Russians very slow and flat-footed and
the reason one of the reasons why the
ukrainians are so good at this is
because of starlink it is a game changer
not many things in the military world
are real game changers but starlink has
been a game changer in their ability to
act as a flexible agile fleet-footed
opponent to a very clumsy Russian
military machine
the cost so far is reportedly about 10
billion dollars that's what Elon Musk
says that SpaceX has put into this whole
styling Enterprise and that's probably
right of course Elon Musk can afford 10
billion but in military terms that's not
so expensive but we could expect it to
cost another 10 billion over the next
six months if the system keeps going at
the present level one of the questions
is will he continue to fund it there's
been some discussion about that and the
Pentagon has said well they will they
will fund it if necessary in their
funding some of it and indeed some of
the European allies are saying well
they'll chip in money if necessary in
order to make sure that the SpaceX
system is still available the starlink
is still being used by the ukrainians
because it's so important to their war
effort nobody wants it to fail simply
through lack of money so 10 billion
dollars so far and Counting it's
probably going to be another 10 billion
over another six months
um there are ways of finding that sort
of money for something as important as
Ukraine's war with Russia
there's some controversy around starlink
because Elon Musk wanted to be a
peacemaker and he came up with a a
negotiated peace plan which was very uh
favorable to the Russians and the
Russians immediately welcomed it and the
ukrainians immediately rejected it and
the suspicion was and the implication of
some of the things he was saying was
that he would use starling's
existence the access that the ukrainians
had to staling as a bargaining ship to
pressurize Kiev into accepting his peace
plan they some of the starlink downlinks
went dead a while ago it really worried
the ukrainians there was a bit of a
crisis of communications a couple of
weeks ago because of that but a lot of
people put pressure on musk the Pentagon
certainly did and the American
Administration did and the Russians did
as well and but he seems to have backed
off and everything has now gone back
pretty well as you were but he's also
trying to become a world Statesman in
Taiwan China relations he has a plan for
that out as well which the Chinese are
quite keen on and the Taiwanese not so
Keen so like most millionaires Elon Musk
tends to be rather eccentric and he he
makes forays into the world of
international politics and starlink
because it's so useful is something of a
bargaining chip for him in relation to
Ukraine Russian issues
[Music]
true to say that there are other
commercial providers but I think this
war marks a new first for civil
technology SpaceX is the first company
to make a significant a significant
difference to the way a battlefield is
conducted private companies have always
contributed to Warfare in one way or
another the defense companies often send
their own technicians out to look after
tanks and armored vehicles and so on
that are being used by their Nation but
this is of a different order this is a a
modern Communications satellite internet
company that is having a major effect in
Warfare and given the
um the maturity now of the revolution in
Satellite technology the fact is that
you you can have cheap small satellites
in low earth orbit in thousands of them
that's not without its problems but they
can be there and they can do astonishing
things and so I think that what SpaceX
has done is to Pioneer a new innovative
Invasion which is predominantly civilian
LED in the pursuit of war and I think
after SpaceX I think there'd be quite a
lot of other companies who find ways of
contributing to the military
machineries of various states in the
world